Sansa Stark and Cersei Lannister - of
Game of Thrones quintessential enemies
despite being on opposing sides like
Westeros they have one thing in common
their clothing and the final season of
the show days before the Battle of
Winterfell both wear high brace
necklines straight chains sculptural
shoulders that evoke armor even stud
work along a central ridge detail their
costumes are as connected as their plot
lines are for most of the show and while
some of the details can get lost in the
show start motif if you look closely
you'll see how much they're parallel
outfits mirror their struggles for power
and identity a new dress did you make it
such a talent they must make something
for me take a look at Circe's outfit
here at King's Landing in season 1
Michelle Clapton the show's Emmy
award-winning costume designer dressed
Cersei and a lot of lightweight pastel
dresses in the first two seasons Pink's
pale purple turquoise within the story
these dresses suggested a feminine queen
and
understated luxury but to the audience
they often signal moments she seemed
powerless now the entire North has risen
up against us they tried to stop it did
you
you failed Circe's pastels play against
her Lannister red dresses to contrast
her moments of power seize him
qasas throat oh wait I've changed my
mind let him go with the color she wore
in her moments of helplessness like this
turquoise dress she wears while watching
her daughter marsala being sent away to
Dorne around the same time Sansa was a
hostage of the crown at the mercy of the
Lannisters wearing dresses that mirrored
her captor Cersei the oversized pastel
hand-me-downs do the same thing for her
that they did for Cersei reflect her
lack of power your grace whatever my
traitor brother has done I had no part
you know that I beg you
they're both as sea drowning and like
color fabric and I'm able to change
their circumstances the Battle of
Blackwater changed all of that before
the battle Cersei was dressed in the
most lannister outfit she could find a
red dress with Lannister liens and an
ornamental breastplate with you guessed
it Lannister lions he didn't end up
being very effective for morale loss to
Chris but it was a show of house power
and Samson's costuming followed suit in
the wake of the battle songs I donned
her own version of a house color purple
it wasn't stark blue but it gave her
more identity than her pastel hostage
hammy dance without rocking the boat too
much around the red Lannisters
it's an early example of a character
dressing and survival camouflage to
blend in with those who pose a threat
but Santa's costuming also shows how
she's begun to assert herself
this starts scarf under her gowns is a
subtle nod to home Cersei season 3
clothes double down on lannister ism as
she assumed the role of queen mother red
everywhere increasingly ornate fabrics
and alliance digital armor and jewelry
but you don't have as clever she thank
you and later in the season sizes
costuming echoed this shift at her
wedding to Tyrion Lannister cloaks the
bride and bring her under your
protection her gown was a purple but
with armored panniers a distinctly
Cersei touch and the show's embroidered
Michelle Carragher included some tricky
embellishments featuring lions
overcoming stark wolves
the embroidery see mimic the way Circe's
Lannister lion signal Authority but made
sure there was something stark on
Santa's dress to the dueling sigil show
how much Sansa had already learned from
Cersei about using clothing to signal
alliances an especially important skill
moving forward
in season four as the two characters
diverge with Cersei vying for power
behind the throne and sounds of
grappling with her identity those
signature colors begin to disappear
Cersei goes dark as she mourns her son
Joffrey how dark well that house sigil
is either studied with skulls or half
rotted so pretty damn dark Santa's
transformation happens after Petyr
Baelish rescues her from King's Landing
and her new circumstances prompt a dress
so important we see her making it
technically the dress signal it sounds
like going undercover as Peters daughter
and know what you wanted to you but the
details straight sleaze like Baelish as
coats feathers evoking has named the
Mockingbird in a gunmetal palette were
pivotal reflecting Souza's keen
awareness of survival camouflage a skill
she learned under Cersei even their
necklaces are echoes a little piece of
armor at the throat as Cersei and sounds
I begin to reassert their power around
season six their gowns become
increasingly stiff and severe and House
loyalty returns to their costuming with
a vengeance
during sanz's northern tour in season
six to rally support against Ramsay
Bolton she wears the Westerosi version
of a graphic tee stark direwolf front
and center you dress myself to like it
the outfit is a clear indicator of how
far she's come into her own power
evidence as she watches Ramsay being
eaten by his own dogs the same way Circe
did jewels signified authority after her
violent bid for the throne with no
further use for the survival camouflage
of feminine queen or splendid Queen
Mother
sir sees gowns at go Lannister armor
with high neck silhouettes and
forbidding fabrics and defensive details
like epaulets reminders of the family's
military might and by the time sounds
it's back in Winterfell on her own terms
in season 7 her wardrobe was high neck
silhouettes and forbidding fabrics the
epaulets and signature necklace echo
stark armor while feathers represent her
time with Baelish reflecting the Stark
family's prestige and the cunning she
uses to govern the north since the women
parted at the purple wedding they've
kept pace with each other strategically
she told you her army was coming Moss to
fight fie she did you believed her and
visually
and by the show's final season Sansa and
Cersei have amassed different kinds of
Authority and have taken different
lessons to heart about what wins a war
well I ensured our stores would last
through winter
I didn't account for Dothraki unsullied
and two full-grown dragons 20,000 men is
it yes your grace an elephants no
elephants your grace that's
disappointing
despite the diverging pot lines as both
of them enter the final battle their
costumes show their similarities rather
than emphasize their differences in the
end they stand on opposite sides with
their costumes clearly echoing each
other and as the show draws to a close
it's safe to say those parallels are
there for a reason
if this video has you thinking about
fashion design you should check out
Skillshare it's an online learning
community with classes and drawing video
animation and more and this classroom
suit where a legend just staple can give
you tips on starting your own fashion
label now you can get two months of
Skillshare for free to sign up visit the
link in the description the first 500
visitors get two months of unlimited
access to over 25,000 classes for free
Skillshare doesn't directly impact our
editorial but their support makes videos
like these possible so you should go
check them out